COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some fishing fashionistas
get a line on their cold boot
performance problems.
Will we catch the big one?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So last episode, I
helped my friend Carter
and his new website,
Bait and Stitch,
which allows fishermen to
meet up with local designers
to create custom apparel.
We were able to do a survey
of the different ways
to profile App Engine startup
time and realized a few things.
Firstly is that GAE standard
startup time is fast.
There's no issues with
the platform there.
Secondly, tracing
was an amazing tool
to see where your time is going,
to RPC or other system calls.
And thirdly, we could augment
those traces with custom data
to get more info on the
performance of the code.
But we didn't actually track
down what the problem was yet.
So to recap, the
Logging Tool showed us
that our loading requests,
and a whole set of requests
afterwards, are taking
significantly longer
than the average, which is
about 3 to 7 milliseconds.
But upon revisiting the
logs, I had a realization.
Check out those time stamps
for those slow requests.
They didn't come in after
the loading request,
but rather at the same time
as the loading request.
The difference between the
loading request and the ones
following are roughly
the same millisecond.
Given this fact, the
way we should really
be looking at this log
data is that there's
two groups of
requests-- one that
arrives at the same time as
the loading requests, which
are slow, and one that
arrives afterwards,
which are actually fast.
And with this shift in
thinking, I suddenly
realized what was wrong--
parallel requests.
See, if you have thread safe
enabled in GAE Standard,
then your application can
receive parallel requests,
which will spin off
to separate threads
to execute work on
the same instance.
This normally is
really important,
given the fact
that it allows you
to maximize your usage of
the instance that you have.
In Carter's case, however,
this is causing a problem,
since something in
the loading request
is causing the rest of
the parallel request
to block until it's completed.
To confirm this, you can look
at the logs in more detail.
You can see that each parallel
request gets subsequently
slower while it waits.
And in some cases,
it's 2x slower
than the loading request itself.
But truth is that this
isn't normal behavior
for parallel requests.
After a bit more
digging, the problem
materialized pretty quickly.
Carter was messing around
with global variables
and parallel requests.
Turns out that in the
instance initialization
for Bait and Stitch sat some
code that looked like this.
When the instance booted
for the first time,
it would query NDB to get
some setting data that it
keeps around for use later.
Now, when you're writing
client-side applications,
work like this really
isn't a big deal,
since this type of
thing is typically
done before your thread
pools are initialized.
But in App Engine,
initialization
can happen in parallel
to your threading work.
The result is that each
one of these threads
will be trying to initialize
the global variables
at the same time.
And since they
aren't thread local,
all the threads
will block and wait
until the work is finished.
This has a significant
performance impact,
since it turns your
parallel system
into a single linear operation.
The solution came from a very
simple realization-- not every
one of our requests actually
used the global variable.
But since the logic
was occurring globally,
all the threads and requests
were blocking on it.
The fix was pretty
easy at this point--
change the global
variable to be lazy
initialized based on the
first instance that uses it.
In this scenario,
Bait and Stitch
still pays the cost,
eventually, to do the NDB query.
But the trick here is
that it's more performant
when the get CDN function
is not causing contention
for other parallel requests.
Once we changed
this code around,
we saw a significant
improvement in performance.
Our loading requests
no longer blocked
the rest of the
parallel requests,
and didn't create the
same blocking behavior.
Now, obviously this
is a specific case.
But you can see how quickly cold
boot time can cause problems
that impact your bottom line.
For those folks who've worked in
managed languages in situations
where startup time matters, most
of this information is old hat.
But in the world
of cloud computing,
these small
performance anomalies
have serious
consequences, not only
for user perception
of performance,
but also in pure costs.
Having 100 loading
requests a day
at 187x slower than
regular requests
starts to result in significant
overhead in compute hours.
Thankfully, we were able to peel
back the layers of complexity,
profile some new
parts of the code,
and save Bait and Stitch
some serious performance
for their users.
And if that sounds
pretty awesome to you,
then make sure you check out the
rest of the Cloud Performance
Atlas videos.
And don't forget-- when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]